he's damian lillard who joins us on the
program from my Portland Trailblazers
house the house what kind of setup do
you have there Daniel my setup is the
same as it always is but I built me a
little recording studio out inside the
house
I got me a game on setup I pretty much
been in the same room every day also
what do you been watching I watched
everything on Netflix same with our last
day like you say you watched a you know
Jojo exotic or the tiger show whatever
that show is the tiger king yeah
everybody was telling me about it but I
haven't that's the only thing I haven't
got around to that's literally the only
thing yeah do you have a basketball hoop
there I got outside oh okay
now are you gonna take part in that game
a horse that virtual horse game that NBA
and ESPN are talking about I'm not a
hundred percent sure but I know
everybody loves all these ideas yeah
Mark Cuban said he was all for that I
thought all right you know I mean who do
you want a piece of and then Ken's ion
what if Zion is in and he dunks like our
dunks gonna be legal in a game of horn I
mean I think it's only right to not not
have Duncan be a part of it no I think
that limits the I guess the amount of
people's to do it you know it's more fun
when there's more based on like trick
shots and skew and stuff like that
because you said your phone up outside
and then you'd shoot a jumper and then
Steph Curry takes the shot that he wants
I guess you could have trick shots I
guess you know we could we could make
this work but who would you want a piece
of right away in the game of horse yeah
I mean I don't know nobody specific I
think if it actually did happen and they
they wanted me to be a part of it I'll
be now I wouldn't really care well plan
i feel like i got a really pretty bad
skill set for a game of horse it
wouldn't really matter to me honest I
saw where Trey Young was on Shaq's
podcast and he said that eventually he's
going to be a better shooter than Steph
Curry that's a thought test but I mean
trade straight and really shoot man any
young you know I think over the course
of his career just from experience you
he'll become even better shooter than he
has now just based off of reps and this
being his job you know he'll be doing it
every single day that's the only thing
he has to do
um so it's not it's not impossible but I
mean Steph was the best shooter to ever
play and I was gonna be that's gonna be
hard for him to to accomplish but I mean
I wouldn't say it's impossible but who
has the best looking jump shot like form
wise if you were gonna change oh yeah
I'm right there with you
I like David Lee yeah do you sample and
like what do you sample from other
scores or shooters I mean for me I just
the the first thing I see his like was
the the quality of the shots that they
get like when I watch James Harden he
makes a lot of toughness and then when I
watched clay clay it's a lot of like
really hard quality look and then once
he's makes those he starts making
everyone no matter how close you are you
got to take a dribble if he's off
balance it doesn't matter and then steps
is just like whatever shot he's taken
look he just looked high-quality his
deep it was off the bounce that you
follow him even when he shoot from like
half quarter half court or 3/4 quarters
like you looking like men I got a chance
to go in but when I watch I'm just
seeing like the looks that they didn't
and automatically compared to like okay
when I get this opportunity am I not
going to down it at the same clip or as
close to one in a position to get this
shot
that's kind of how I watch it and I try
to position myself and use some of the
things that I see them do to get certain
shot so I can get them for myself
Blazers guard Damian another joining us
on the program who's most likely to make
a run at Kobe's 81 points in a game most
likely to make a run at Kobe's 81 mm I
think I'm suddenly a part of their group
yeah so I got I did the 81 anything I
would say Devin Booker I would say
myself I would say harden harden for
sure and then another person always what
was the maybe clay yeah
well clay scored what do you get thirty
seven and a quarter thank you yeah like
he just stuff he had joy spurts you know
the whole game they just have a hot
streak in that he'll move you know get
off the ball and he sit on the bench for
like longer periods of time but clay is
just like super aggressive he catch it
he firing and once you get going they
like force-feed him they find them and
like he ain't shot he's fired and fired
and fire so I think I'll say clay myself
Devin Booker James Harden and maybe I
mean Luca does it can Luca do something
like that with the Greek freak I think
Lucas as far as well for Luca to do it I
mean Luca is just like he can really
shoot but is like a LeBron type of game
like he's just you know kind of play
game Genesis and you know getting score
bunches and stuff like that to oxalá
anyone is just like your bucket getter
like I can see ya like that super
aggressive can really shoot all that
stuff
and you got to be a gunner and have no
conscience that always helps we're got
to be somebody and just go for it
what have you been told about this
season I'm really freaked out a whole
lot of information I I've heard that the
NBA is trying their best and these allow
us to finish it that they don't want it
is you know be canceled to have a
champion and not be able to complete the
season I've heard that and know that
exploring our options
so was it what would it be like to play
in an empty arena I don't know I mean it
would be crazy to you because I've never
turns that as an NBA player and we claim
such huge arenas and you know we become
accustomed to a certain type of
environment I went to a small college so
I played in 2020 you know 2,500 people
in the building I played in plenty of
those I guess it wouldn't be completely
crazy for me but it's been a while well
hopefully you're not going to stir crazy
and we look forward to you maybe getting
involved in the horse game yeah B it
could be fun yeah well I wonder how that
would be like where they just have us
play or would that be like a painting or
what it'd be like how do you how do they
do that I think it would be just they
would they would have a time frame where
you would start your game with Steph
Curry and you guys would do it in real
time where you had the camera on you you
took a shot if you made it then he has
to match it and you miss it then he goes
he makes you know then you do that
and maybe you know it's gonna be on ESPN
and maybe they can raise money or
something like that but I don't know I
mean it's just like I guess they would
have to recruit at home I guess they'll
just take everything in take the video
and play yeah yeah and then you set up
brackets and then you go you know this
this is the matchup tonight at 7 o'clock
this is the matchup at 7:30 matchup and
and they could edit it down I mean
you're a producer you know how we could
do this you can put in put in some music
in there put a music bet in there maybe
put in some of your music from your you
know one of your albums and we can make
this fun yeah yeah throw it in there
later on man product placement that's
what it's all about
hey great to talk to you we appreciate
your time hopefully we get chance see
back out on the court there and thanks
for joining us
likewise when I appreciate you that's a
Damian Lillard five-time all-star